I cannot in his King Tut's father Queen
taiye and I'm gonna have to III was uh
came to us grandfather and grandmother
Akhenaten he got in big trouble because
when you go to Egypt if you ever notice
all those chipped away Gods all those
people are tripped away all their faces
away that was under the order initially
who started that Akhenaten so Akhenaten
decided I'm going to become a
monotheistic uh ruler and not you know
not the kind of believes in multiple
gods and so and what got into him was
Amin Raw who's also Felts brother his
brother his name is Marduk in the Bible
in the Jewish Torah but in Egypt his
name is uh Aman ra he's the one who said
whenever you give thanks you say Amen to
me you give thanks to me this is why
people say amen they're not saying Amen
to the creator of the universe they're
actually saying Amen to this guy who
says a brutal killing ruler an evil dude
who was so jealous he said scratched
that from my vocab listen he said
there'll be no other God but me that was
the terminology that made it into the
actual biblical text I'm a jealous guard
that made it into the biblical text why
would the creative Universe be jealous
why would the creative Universe demand
that other gods which means there are
other gods I'm surprised they have left
it in there you know exist and so this
was almond Rod talking and you could
look him up on the Jewish American
library and all that stuff his name is
all over the place he's all in there
interacting and talking and creating all
kind of issues and problems and he told
akhanatan that you worship me and you
get everyone to worship me and deface
all the other gods so I could not and
started ordering and decreeing that all
these things be chipped away everywhere
you go chipped away to faces chip away
the ears the Romans when I went yeah no
no no I could not go into the Super
ancient history you find it Akhenaten
that's why he was kicked out of Egypt he
was kicked out of Egypt and when he left
Egypt he went to the king to the Great
Pyramid and he went to that stone box
area inside the king chamber and took
the Ark of the Covenant with him see
Akhenaten is Moses
that's the Moses story he takes that
with him he flees with all his new
followers there were no slaves in Egypt
I'm gonna say this again there were no
slaves in Egypt working on pyramids
their people had their home slaves but
they were nobody building pyramids we
know this for a fact because we have all
the work records we discovered all the
broken legs broken arm records we have
all the payroll records all of them
yes it's all done we have oh it's all in
the museum now so we have all the
information that showed these people
were paid they had insurance they had
coverage and all this we know for a fact
that these people were not slaves the
people that were this this Exodus that
left out of Egypt they were the people
who converted from believing in multiple
gods to believing in the one God
religion monotheism following Akhenaten
and he fled with all these people out of
Egypt with the Ark of the Covenant and
that's why the powers that be sent an
army after and they're like you took the
source of our power with you we got to
have that and they fled after him he
never crossed the Red Sea when you
that's a mistranslation in the Bible he
crossed the Sea of reeds which is a
closer much smaller sea and when you do
their geological rewind which we have
the computer model simulate now around
that same time frame that this happened
there was a massive earthquake and a
tsunami estimated to be in that region
which means it would have sucked all the
water out and would have come crashing
back
so you see how stories get remixed
what's happened there was a natural
disaster and perfect timing
um but they they did ended up in the
desert with the Ark of the Covenant
which is well noted and documented in
biblical text all right so what was the
ark of the covenant a super Advanced
technological machine it was
multi-purposeful we know this because of
the way that it's designed and what it
reads you know what it says what it was
capable of doing it's a weapon but it
also has a capability of being a power
source so it does multiple things and to
handle it you have to have lead
okay you had to have these special kind
of boots on because it was a capacitor
and some scientists at several
universities experimented with
recreating The Arc using the
instructions that are in the Bible and
it was so powerful they had to shut it
down what yeah this is anybody can
Google this this is like it was
mainstream news about maybe 15 years ago
they've done this already they've
reproduced it and it actually turned on
what did the cherubs do what did the
Angels the cherubs do what were there
electricity yes exactly a big spark when
you look up the video on YouTube You'll
see a big spark jumping across an arc
that's the arc that's why they call it
the ark it's the arc which is the you
know the electromagnetic Arc as jumps
from one cherubim to the next
I've also heard that incense and and the
smoke from it was used to be able to see
the energy
be able to see like the electricity and
the energy working that it was part of
its the away to and that's kind of where
some of the
incense became ceremonial it's like when
you see a laser show they have to put
that mist out there yeah it's like light
the air yes exactly same same exact
thing that's exactly what they did
there are more than one Arc too there
wasn't there's more than one ARP that is
correct there's more than one Arc there
was more than one Arc
um they've all been taken now so nobody
knows where they are the last one that
we knew of was in Ethiopia we had an
Ethiopian church and a guy discovered it
there about seven or eight years ago and
he went public with it and then within a
year it was stolen from there because
there was no military no no police no
security just some Temple and uh Church
priests you know guarding it so they
took it very easily and I was the last
one known him that was publicly
available the rest are probably in some
type of a military bunker I think Graham
Hancock did a pretty deep dive on the
art and they the anybody that interacted
with the ark would essentially not want
the job because they would die yeah they
would die there or they would get what
looked like radiation sickness their
eyes would start bleeding their nose and
start bleeding their nails would fall
off their skin would boil their hair
would fall out that sounds like
radiation sickness so what did they use
it for in ancient times where it was
productive the Great Pyramid itself is a
power generator that's one of the
purposes just that's just one it was a
multifunctional stone computer also but
just for the purposes of this
it was built on top of an aquifer and
the knot used to run very close to the
pyramids on Giza now it's way mannered
way way all the temples all the temples
have their ramps and you can see that it
doesn't look like normal steps like the
water was right up to like all the
temples right exactly right up to them
and the water running underneath the
Great Pyramid would run underneath in
that aquifer and that moving water would
then run right underneath the uh solid
Granite magnetized Granite uh that was
their Crystal Granite now when you have
running water against magnetized Crystal
Granite which is the base there it
creates physiostatic electricity those
ions would get pushed up into the grand
gallery and they had used to have
resonating rods in the slots going up
the grand Gallery when it got to the
king's chamber some other type of you
know Fusion would happen and it would
then send the energy up through the Apex
and the Apex which is now missing would
then transmit it out wirelessly to the
Obelisk which then collect this ambient
electricity and if you had a Jed you can
pick up this ambient wireless
electricity you can see the jet
connected to light bulbs and so forth
like a narrow the one the jet has the
three or four bars on it exactly and so
Nikola Tesla copied that same Energy
power technique with the wooden Cliff
Tower and so what at when the water
shifted away began to meander away and I
think it really happened after the last
pyramid War it broke the stone computer
it broke the stone uh power generator
and so what they realized was we can
take this Arc and we could put it in
this they made this makeshift Granite
box which is not a sarcophagus because I
can't even fit in I'm six foot four
I said just fine I was totally fine my
my toning inside of the Box felt sounded
great nice but it's definitely not big
enough I've ever seen the real ones
they're giant they're massive I had to
bend my niece so I knew it wasn't a
sarcophagus but it's the same exact I
measured it it's the same exact
dimensions as what the Ark of the
Covenant identical Dimensions which
means it fit right in that box and so if
you don't have the water you need
something else to Arc the power perfect
location to put it in the king's chamber
to send the energy through the Apex so
they can keep the wireless wireless
energy going energy yeah so when
Akhenaten took that he took the power
source for Egypt send you right back in
time if you don't have power and also no
one would want that right now because
institutions would lose billions of
dollars because you would be allowing
free energy free energy puts everyone on
the equal playing field you know no more
third world country if you got energy
and water everybody's equal and they
don't want that they want to keep the
boot on the necks of the people and
control and hoard the power in one
region so they can dominate the rest of
the planet what do you believe the
temples were used for temples had a
couple of different purposes one they're
built on top of these uh extreme
magnetic fields and so in some way they
would harness those magnetic fields for
some type of energy purposes in some way
they were utilizing this energy for like
the Fountain of Youth that utilize it to
for for anti-aging techniques anti-aging
methods also there's a couple of temples
that people sick people will be allowed
to go into right it would walk between
these two magnetized Granite plates and
it would heal them for the Anunnaki
Atlantean people or the Pharaohs it was
anti-aging they've done experiments
inside of some of these temples and some
of these similar magnetic fields where
plants grow twice as fast and are more
abundant uh and so you know they were
they were built plus also the design of
them had ancient secrets and Mysteries
encoded into the actual construction
technique right that was left behind for
people to read people who knew the brick
masons and so forth they get information
from these structures and buildings in
the pattern of the building of the
temple like how the rooms were organized
how you'd walk through it yeah if you
like this clip and you want to hear the
whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen